il est temps maintenant de rejoindre
notre invité jean paul belmondo dont le
prochain film sort mercredi son titre
n'est pas vraiment de saison puisque
s'intitule joyeuses pâques
il est réalisé par georges lautner jean
paul belmondo qui est en direct avec
nous depuis son bureau parisien en
compagnie de france roche bonsoir jean
paul et merci d'être là ce soir car on
ne vous voit que très rarement à la
télévision alors justement pourquoi
êtes-vous si avare de vos interventions
baâziz en jeu sous la barre des
interventions pour pas lasser le public
parce que on va boire la au cinéma dans
beaucoup de salles si en plus on me voit
sans arrêt à la télévision il y aura
saturation
c'est une tactique très réfléchi en
définitive voilà c'était une tactique
alors renoncer à votre film joyeux spike
qui est si j'ai bien compris c'est un
peu un bout de ville et la sauce
belmondo en quoi se différencie en quoi
dit certes il des autres films du même
genre
ben disons que c'est un film qui a été
écrit par jean poiret d'un gars tout
l'humour de jean poiret fivois
personnellement me fait beaucoup rire et
diffère que là c'est un personnage
disons très gai et qui n'est pas du tout
dans mystère
ni un dur oui même une différence
d'altitude vous êtes un tombeur de dames
vous êtes libre vous passez elle tombe
dit que cette fois ci à la fois sophie
marceau et marie laforêt vous joue un
certain nombre de tours au lieu d'être
un tombeur vous êtes un peu attendait
oui elle me donne du mal j'ai du mal
avec les deux mais finalement par
moments on croit qu'ils et qu'il est
tombé mais il sait se redresser je crois
qu'il ya une fin très optimiste vous
êtes producteur coproducteur de vos
films vous allez donc choisir vos
partenaires pourquoi sophie marceau
pourquoi marie laforêt il va écouter
d'abord dans ce film je suis associé
avec mon ami alain sarde qui avait déjà
engagé
sophie marceau et donc c'était une très
bonne idée
c'est une très bonne actrice et marie
laforêt mon dieu parce que j'ai déjà
fait deux films avec elle est une
actrice qui a tout à fait le sens de la
comédie
donc c'est un rôle qui n'était pas
facile à jouer et pas facile à à trouver
un personnage comme ça donc c'était
maria fort de votre expérience et sophie
marceau qui marque tels que fini
derrière elle qu'est ce que ça donne
comme couple va écouter c'est elle est
très bien je pense parce que sophie
marceau m'a beaucoup surpris parce
qu'elle a elle a déjà beaucoup de métier
mais au bon sens du mot et en plus c'est
une jeune fille qui joue vraiment la
comédie c'est à dire qu'elle a de l'oeil
ne pense pas si je veux tout le temps
comme certaines actrices elle vous
regarde elle joue et si on improvise et
suit dans l'improvisation
et puis je dirais qu'en plus comme
camarade elle est vraiment adorable et
ce qui est rare pour les gens de la
génération est là pas du tout la grosse
tête ça se fait rare quand jean paul
belmondo j'ai vu la bande annonce de ce
film dans lequel vous jouez donc le rôle
d'un à tomber on cite aline un peu on y
casse des voitures on y comme beaucoup
est ce que c'est ça la recette belmondo
bad et j'aimerais avoir une recette
belmondo ou mais je dirais que moi
j'aime beaucoup faire des acrobaties en
voiture il se trouve que j'ai des dons
pour ça donc les exploitent et il se
trouve aussi que j'ai toujours la forme
pour le faire et en plus je crois que le
public aime bien pouvoir faire tout ça
donc tout le monde est content mais on
va voir que vous avez la forme dans la
seine
on est atteint voilà ce qu'elle aime les
tyrans les dictateurs mais on sourit
beaucoup par la tête ils ont ballon
reste dans une mine de sel parce que
c'est un sinistre le conte ou chaud faut
quand même avoir le courage de le lui
dire hier au lieu de vous tordre sur le
canapé comme une serpillière on est
surpris vous james bond à la panique le
007 du des kilos tard pour tout et pour
voir s'il est paniqué le second
bout de temps
pas de queue
coup de pioche
voilà donc pour cet extrait jean paul
belmondo sur un autre registre vous avez
bien connu françois truffaut qui mort
hier il avait été le scénariste d' à
bout de souffle qui le film qui vous a
lancé
il a également réalisé la sirène du
mississipi quels sont vos souvenirs de
françois truffaut
j'ai des très bons souvenirs avec
françois truffaut puisque j'ai eu la
chance de le connaître
à mes débuts qui était également un peu
ses débuts a vu aussi et nous avions
fait aussi un voyage en amérique du sud
du sud pour promotionner le cinéma
français est en effet l'argentine le
brésil et j'ai le souvenir d'un homme
charmant timide à l'époque truffaut été
assez étonnant n'allait are you on
allait tous sur la plage être il faut
rester blanc comme un linge est restée
dans sa chambre ou détesté le soleil
mais vraiment détesté il avait une haine
pour ça a pris il a évolué beaucoup emma
ce qui valait beaucoup frappé ce qu'il y
avait des conférences de presse
ce n'était pas commode et à chaque fois
on laisser la parole à truffaut qui
était d'une intelligence rare et d'une
précision fantastique
l'équipe ne pouvait jamais le coincer il
avait toujours la phrase exacte est donc
là de ce côté-là il m'avait beaucoup
ébloui et après quand j'ai fait la
sirène du mississipi avec lui j'ai adoré
travailler avec lui parce que c'est un
homme qui aimait énormément les acteurs
mais les aimais sincèrement il avait un
grand plaisir à vous voir jouer il
aimait bien faire faire des prises pour
le plaisir de voir jouer les acteurs et
je crois que ça c'était une grande
qualité à part ces grands dons que nous
connaissons tous c'est que c'est
regrettable que 13 fois nos équipes et
merci jean paul belmondo j'ajoute à cela
que des personnalités du monde entier
ont rendu hommage